all right and free Oh laughs welcome to
the i lords podcast episode number 91
and it's another glorious Sunday we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got the game award
recap Xbox game pass coming to every
device Microsoft looking to acquire a
historically solis to do a possible
sequel to a beloved Microsoft franchise
and smash impressionist to discuss so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who's knowing on the
rise of the content creator but provides
one of the most balanced perspectives in
our gaming community this Lord's passion
for gaming and sci-fi is evident in
everything he does well at the same time
providing a one-stop shop for the Xbox
platform introducing that creator and
host of the shop podcast the lord of
insightful commentary family man it's
Saturday evenings host with the most
making his debut into the realm of the
Lord's mom made Lord ptk blame how are
you doing sir I'm good sir you're far
too kind o man but I appreciate it man
thank you for reaching out this is
something that me and even patent works
for awhile he's been on the show before
so nice to meet everybody here on a
realm it's truly an honor to be on
you're talking games but everybody I
cannot wait to dive I don't know I feel
like it's like an arrival I appreciate
you guys thank you buddy
absolutely long overdue me and bland
been in the lab building for us to get
this thing you know he had me in the
room with a shop man shoutout to your
team thank you yeah use Orca fuzzy the
whole squad show tremendous love we had
a great time so it's only right we
brought you back in the room we gonna
have fun today you already know let's
get it let's get it we have the force
would have gaming
those original Lords of the realm here
at the round table
my co-host would the core most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game
Kankuro and the house of the young Oh
mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good yes sir that's what I like
that energy hard I know you're not
feeling well so that's good
anything else going on what you've been
playing man
the mutineer zero and that's about all I
played a little bit of smash oh yeah I'm
gonna talk about that a tional we're
gonna get into that later we can get
into it no doubt and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sashka
darkness mister offline profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir I'm
doing good man doing pretty damn good I
have I have a little bit of energy we
got you for like what we got you caught
off one on the dot man to one of the
dots lady psalmist has decreed the
hammer down yesterday yesterday we had
to rejigger some stuff for a birthday so
today so ok God have you in limited
capacity but still have what's been
going on with you reclaimer
us only smash I only got having at it I
downloaded all the new stuff the the
Devil May Cry demo with the ashen
everything on xbox I haven't gotten back
to Red Dead when I got that smash I said
you know what let me try a little bit of
this at work yo they have a fan man they
have a new fan I'm uh I've never ever
played smash ever like when smash was
big
initially unlike the n64 then the
Gamecube like I was you know you know us
we were playing wrestling like we
weren't about smash again like I'm at
the point I could I'll try anything and
I gotta say man like this is
besides King stating the obvious that is
something I definitely want to get
because I want to expose my son to it
yeah um and I want to expose them to the
Pokemon so during the winter solstice
we're gonna go out and we're gonna shop
and he's gonna definitely get those
games to play on the switch yeah yeah I
mean I will say this only won't play on
my switch that smash was like the
biggest love letter to all things
Nintendo like is really like it's
overwhelming the amount of stuff in that
game but and of course I don't even know
if I call you the incredible a the
access game oh the lord of combat sports
who's a man it was convictions demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement Oh beloved Lord
King how you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic ever you feel like you should
be in a mental ward on your forehead I
know you understand anything
you would think is a fairy because you
know nothing of opulence sir they're not
shocking what opulence is is gold Libra
gold knee
whoa spec the crown shut up now frauds
out here running around with we won you
won nothing you want absolutely nothing
what did you make did you contribute
anything to a game and purchased a game
people in my inbox talking about did you
check it out did you see in watching the
show absolutely nothing but their bucks
so stop all this is about this I want
you to get this because listen image is
key at all times if you don't think when
he walked up on stage you look at his
eyes he looked at his pivot point on he
had marks on the stage yes
the way he stepped on that X proved to
me exactly he knew I don't know if they
had to pay for these spots but I know he
was gonna be in the center is a cap is
the center the visualization of the
whole thing is key
and y'all gotta understand this part and
that's not a lead into what cockney toes
gonna talk about later well he filled
ominous with no games winning Game of
the Year nothing like that who's the
talk of the show come on oh yeah side of
your game awards recap what if you play
exam I've been playing xbox stop stop
digging window Ward's good stuff - yo
how does that feel your boot that um I
want y'all understand something that we
say that it feels like feces in your
socks drop in a drop day in date and
game past which is one dollar and where
do you get the store like that that
winter of arcade crazy Oh a [ __ ] in here
you go yeah below you and Year Zero I
mean man and it wasn't it one more blame
that we forgetting this woman I thought
they're not as well but it looked really
strong I have to admit if you can
combine that right yeah I'm game for
gold this month single-handedly is like
a knockout blow it's like a disrespect
all this is over here bruh were you
playing that bro
what are you really doing with yourself
Phil Dominus isn't building he's putting
his foot down on you bro
but the argument could be said to God oh
forget that
oh my god but anyway no no I won nothing
though you know what I did window I want
ashen
[Laughter]
the Royal opulent forum gotta respect it
got the godly good and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
Lord kognito spreading that ruinous in
the rum an ILP not telling you what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
so first up mission one finish
welcome to bonus days shout out to my
man Lord real Taz D on Twitter man he
asked Lord Cognito a classic should know
B challenge question so I had to dig in
a crate song I had to pull out my xbox
archive because he thought the kid never
beat a bonus stage or what I had to pull
it up you know me
shoutout to tragedy it was it wasn't it
no malice it was just fun you just say
yeah I see you it should don't be fair
but have you have you done the rails so
of course you either had to show them I
had it all documented put it up there on
on Twitter right quick just play the
actual okay actually what I did was a
shout out to Bill Stillwell in the back
would compare because we have the arcade
version shinobi from the 360 on back
compact on an Xbox one
arcade perfect with fully adjustable
settings but on the stage you can't you
can't change those settings on that
that's skill let me tell you something
Lord kognito was the only one with an
arcade machine in his house that we came
over to play shoutout to Cognito
forgetting that round no reroll and
under all of us in front of everyone got
an individual fake yes except but yeah
shoutout to tas d man that's my homie
you know saying and we had to show them
that perfect completion but yeah other
than that for me it's been on destiny
too black army the little I can play
because I'm not up to level to touch it
shoutout to any parties will talk we
talked about that off flashpoint and got
to touch some smash don't know what I'm
doing don't know what the hell's going
on haha download it Ashley mu0 so I got
a check get a chance to touch that but I
get did get a chance to touch a closed
beta of a highly anticipated game
dropping next year
all I'm going to say because I'm under
NDA is they are coming this game I am
the biggest skeptic of and they are
coming if for them to get to have me
have wow moments you don't say slow-mo I
know allegedly he wants receipts is a
highly anticipated game I say is for me
the biggest skeptic of said game it gave
me wow moments there's still a lot of
questions we still shall see more but
that's all I have to say on the matter
see we done did you see the article
about a certain someone who lost who
broke in the air and I'm like to take a
screenshot tempted to put up some man
you gotta respect the rules to the game
but um yeah that's pretty much it man so
that's what we got on what the Lord's
have been playing I want to start off
what actually before we do that we gotta
um
real quick I forgot to do the patreon
thing really quickly go for that one so
uh big shout out to our brother Lord
loaded pixels last week he won two
giveaways and he was gracious enough to
pay his $10 when forward so we're gonna
reroll that right now he did yeah he
also get away
yeah we got a W today he uh he decided
to keep the game know that I gotta get
these like sighs we bout to give away
some stuff come on y'all
come on Lords thank you thank you go for
it
all right so the winner of the rear old
$10 gift card giveaway Lord I'm ed
Hernandez new to the patreon world solo
solo - no - Louis solving the damn you
know say if he catches a low-salt please
reach out to him if you have yes sir I
got you yeah battening the coffers I
wanna start up with Lord blame sir
system history his journey is a content
creator and what led him to form the
one-stop shop for all things in gaming
the shop podcast so Lord let's start
from the beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
um man really I was a Sega kid I was a
Sega keep growing up I'm not gonna lie
though my favorite all-time game ever
ever
history is Zelda Ocarina time so that's
my favorite all-time game ever made the
question you say
oh yeah no fantasy thoughtfulness right
now anyway that was my first experience
with video games you like the phone
control yeah wait oh wait so my sister
actually bought me the first Xbox umm
burning in a little sister worked all
summer and tell her she bought it for
Madden even asked for it
let me back it there's a second yeah
didn't that prompted her like like maybe
you showed interest in something or she
just knew you had your eye on it or I
think she'd know I had my eye on it
because I've been Xbox guy ever since
haven't gone back probably I'm not a
hater or Playstation don't get me wrong
I do love PlayStation as well God of War
is my one of my second or third favorite
franchise ever no huge fan at that so I
mean that's really my let me answer got
a back you know could you spend you know
because I heard Sega low but I yeah so
yeah I need to know what was the titles
that actually kind of ingratiating you
to say um ultra beasts yeah eyes from
your grave yeah yeah that was that was
me my me and my friend you said we used
to literally sit up all night playing
over Nick over and over again um what
else was out playing I was a big Joe
Montana as well you know just the first
I used to I literally had a game you
know my channel righteous fate put it
one and a half back pass that's too low
twos on say obviously the Sonics you
know so I mean that was it that was a
huge thing but those is kind of my
staples man got it was some other game
sprinkled in and out of there but those
it's really like Oh mortal combat
- oh by the way Nintendo we got the
blood y'all got the green stuff from us
console say console standpoint was an
assist is was it when did it stop did
you get to dream cash like what was the
last Sega systems Dreamcast was the last
one okay cradle to the grave
all this fanboys stuff he was actually
there to witness turbo graphics die use
actually there to witness SNK go-to way
of making multi plats and he was
actually there to watch um somebody
who's actually there to watch Sega die
like and these guys is sitting there
with all this furor talking about me
against you and you actually witnessed
deficit companies and other companies
rise in and take that spot and it's just
futile to have these console wars how do
you feel like knowingness and seeing it
like from the outside cuz you just said
yo I got a PlayStation I like
PlayStation there's no hate yeah coming
from that how do you you know perceive
these console wars and these guys on
Twitter going crazy for no reason
the difference is social media that's
the difference that's that's the entire
difference because what we are
playground arguing Mario Sonic there was
no Instagram I couldn't jump on Twitter
and say I hate for you these
conversations in person I can't go just
jump on the internet and instantly get
access to a million people from my
Twitter you know so I think that's the
biggest difference in social media it's
funny to me though it really is
hilarious because at the end of the day
we would just talk about it pretty show
that you know you got Phil Sean lately
Reggie on stage
these guys are businessman you can't
understand standpoint they don't have
any yes it there's a competitive fire
that you can faces but there's no strife
between any of them it's time to give
buddy you talking about we are fierce
business not do and shout out to you
King because you this you didn't see who
was standing in the middle of that we
yeah we saw I'm sorry I'm just saying I
think I think it's futile yeah I don't I
don't promote a lot of you to go back in
my archives you don't see much of that
yeah ever I bring it up here in there
just to kind of address it but you never
get that so um you know I'm from the
standpoint you are we cut from a little
bit of a different cloth you already
know know that's big when I'm glad you
said that that's actually not very huge
yeah history is impressive from the
saiga standpoint that is very very cool
so you got that Xbox and from me that's
kind of like the love of failure you
start a dead no yes yeah you eat the net
came we would you one of the first early
Xbox Live you know what I'm saying a
doubt I wasn't sure I was it because we
were the only person I had iMac although
if you guys remember to hold the
different color imax who the purple I
have one of those and I was wanted a few
people actually had internet but I
didn't really get it till I moved out on
my team and I don't think the internet
till then so with I say would you say
you were more online during the 360 era
as opposed Laura so yeah for sure I was
doing the system lengthy is carrying
around TV for the win
so I then that's when I got the internet
halo 2 was the online gaming halo 2
multiplayer so oh I changed the game
yeah yeah Cole he said King look like
some dude I killed in Assassin's Creed
[Laughter]
yeah you stupid code you stupid for that
one show the bone he said he had the
iMac also that's a plan we had two TVs
in oh yeah or lab we were going to
people's houses setting up that system
link oh yeah 360 and then that contest
so you didn't have PlayStation and all
during that ever pretty much actually I
did ps2 present in the household my
sister played that quite a bit
I did I didn't I didn't actually play it
as often I had a lot of friends that had
ps3 I didn't jump on the ps3 at all I
[Music]
played a lot of that a lot of that I
can't think of it is the other fighter
not played on ps2 but yeah PlayStation
was in the household a little bit
everybody journey into YouTube obviously
you had some earlier sense prior but
what led you to settling in and then
becoming the blame and then like
creating that shot podcast and obviously
shout out to your team soccer fuzzy
velvety I was a jarhead
so she tell me about that man um you
know the funny thing about this is that
Oh shout-out to mooch did all of this
coming together oh I was I Carly 2013
after the whole fallout what else yeah
so I was at before a different opinion
during that time and right I reached out
on youtube has any other opinions
because at the time I was getting mind
you just like everybody else was 19
GameSpot all these other people
and then we're burying Xbox I'm like
wait I got a different opinion so I
reached out and it was literally nobody
on YouTube at all with a different
opinion so I found like one person I'm
not not gonna be a hater shoutout to
zzzz I hear that's what um he was he's
100 he was one of the only people I had
a different offense still yes yeah for
sure and I found this video he kind of
inspired me to kind of do my own thing
and then I felt crap at that point top
of other people mooch to me and mooch
actually playing video games together
not even realizing I was on my friends
list I saw him on be TST didn't even
realize Rick you talk about it the
Godfather's an excellent movement back
in the day absolutely they kind of
inspired me to do my own thing funny
story is via which have been jamming
each other all summer to start a chat we
literally were hitting each other on
xbox do when you gonna start to tell now
here and we're going back and forth we
started it like two days of art same
week exactly um so that's gonna have
everything started but I am back on my
BS back man and like I said I love the
content came across your content and I
was like yeah very very even though like
I said your platform you definitely
prefer the Xbox brand if you definitely
give a balanced perspective and it's not
just all fanboying out it's just real
real talk and I'm saying so I was very
impressed and obviously got a chance to
get on the show and stuff like that and
then like which would how did you create
your team how did you get walking them
guys and fuzzy and those guys together
it's crazy because my show is go through
a ton of forms just go to a ton of
different iterations so I don't know if
you look at my archives there's a lot of
people that are on my show yes
they kind of caught they're not
obviously caught their break but they're
on my show before they wrote it ever
anything yes I saw some names I was yeah
that was crazy
Aaron Greenberg was on my very first Tim
dog my very first show um I don't know
if you guys the Oh Chris oh yeah he was
on the very first show as well um never
mind
oh yeah
oh yes you better you know send them
ticket out there yeah Rand Rand as well
online I always have bunch people saw it
they kind of it kind of built some air
man is going through a lot of iterations
I have way too many people to shout out
I'm not even gonna attempt it you guys
know if you are that contributed pred
everybody I mean everybody's been also
but amazing so I think we got a good fit
right now I love the song is amazing jar
is always amazing fuzzy green guy
shout-out to fuzzy guys I got a Rolex so
what he had a 20 year anniversary at his
job you got a Rolex that man plays more
Forza oh my god play more for any time
you ask him what he played it's always
what he is a car fanatic yes to him no
let's be he's not playing it's watching
him asleep in the chair while it's going
on to the shop ah thank you thank you
doing that barbershop feel there with
your friends and just talking man and I
had to show love so I got to ask the
question to question before we get out
of here um first was the name I gotta
get the name though what's the science
behind PT k blam you know what uh you
guys remember game battles game battles
came bad I'm I don't know I just
it stood for part-time killers because
we all were like full-time so we kind of
kind of play on the word you know
full-time part-time enemy oh that's
where it came from
blam was just self I threw in there you
guys remember when the Xbox I think it
was oh gee Xbox on Halo used to be able
to use to like auto-generate a name you
can yes you can either put your own in
yes school does he say yeah he remember
gamebattles
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that was before
that was that was that was we used to go
on game battle set up the game set up a
game show up crazy it was when the third
annual Ghost Recon advanced warfare now
we gotta ask the important question we
ask every guest okay so we got number
two is gonna be halo halo og halo halo
see okay then I gotta go
three they take the second and third
spot oh no Fame okay oh yeah you could
go franchise okay
halo is a franchise third third has to
be God award I'm to to specifically be
in my favorite too nice
after that gears is gonna be 400 yes
five this is personal you know what this
is probably gonna become popular but I
don't know for you huge Borderlands fan
as well you're the first you're the it's
just there's a million it started the
whole looter shoot people don't realize
that you would have destiny without
borderlands yeah you wouldn't have you
know division you know and it's still
doing things that game still does it
still offers a different experience I
think the other ones can't offer as far
as the characters like yes the chat is
with you slow motion modeling started at
all oh yes a boy lands overlooked yeah
we know that's a strong look don't that
would be under barren strong very strong
sir
so we go get it to the show last week's
poll results are in and the people have
spoken to the question in regards to the
continued negative press and a fallout
76 has received regarding Metacritic
reviews
game functionality and the collectors
edition better hit do you think media
outlets have been unfairly adopted a
pylon mentality in regards to the game
the answers oh wow this was much closer
than expected lords the winner and a
razor close forty nine percent was the
no fallout 76 game quality and Bethesda
themselves are to blame
coming in at second place at razor close
forty five percent was the yeah
fallout 76 is an easy target for
clickbait journalism and those who have
not played the game and coming in at 6%
was that I don't care that premium
canvas fixes everything though in last
week's poll or bland what do you feel
about that whole fallout 76 teen what
side did you fall on oh man you know
what's funny thing is we talked about
this previously on the show last we got
they you know we talked about this
extensively extensively and I have been
super critical of Bethesda because I
have such a fond memory of Bethesda end
but this always comes from the
standpoint is that modesta when you
think of a tester that was that was
always quality you always talking block
me you're getting a triple-a experience
nothing less and for me I think but
there's its optimal continuous if the
other generation especially with the
game right fallout I'm not holding back
when it comes with this I really have
our I really can't I can't lie I can't
lie so I've been really critical it was
messy fallout 76 because the experience
that was sold wasn't essentially what
was brought to the table isn't nothing
half price right now yeah already
already already I'm with you man I think
it also we talked about earlier Nega man
on and everyone on and praxic excuse me
that um I'm almost glad it happened not
in a bad way like I was something bad on
a company but just more like absolutely
it not they needed their watershed home
it's it cuz they get their act together
remember what movie was going through a
couple girl it reminds me of okay we
need to stop we need to take it break we
know we know elder scrolls is on the
horizon you've already shown at
essentially that is coming um I think
they need to dedicate every single
person at the studio towards I gave at
this point listen take a break I get it
to go all out especially think about it
think about it I think this is why and
what makes me think that especially if
you see that outer worlds trailer whoa
no worse but when you see something like
that come out from the same people that
made probably the best ever Fallout New
Vegas no arguably arguably the best if
we fall out you start to see the
difference and what you so you start to
see the difference in quality and it's
it's it's its glaring it's a huge
difference and I think what doesn't need
to go back to the drawing board and
start over I think they need a bullet
ooby take a little bit of time off movie
is in a really is done phenomenal I
think that ever since they started
publishing games they've they've been
taking too much on ever since they've
started publishing games for other
people it's taking away from the quality
that their games get and it's like
distributed among the people that
they're publishing for yeah it could be
just one of those things just like you
said and bland said right you know
they've kind of fold out got a little
too ahead of themselves I think they
feel that if they could put out a
half-hearted effort it would still go on
the course like you know they're gonna
fall out because I know it was a red
flag when they say we got DLC yes and
we're not gonna tell you what's in the
DLC but by the season passage if you
don't buy it by tomorrow at 3 o'clock oh
yeah the crap and be honest which that's
the probably the only DLC they came out
and I was like hmm
like what this is the one where we have
to build shelters like I it was the mall
it that's when I knew something was up
with them and then I saw the the the 76
coming
and I was in the crowd like everybody
else in the what they promised I was
like I'm down with that I can get with
income in on this I swear I said yeah
and it specifically those Todd Howard
games like they're doing fine on the you
know like dishonored the the Wolfenstein
stuff that stuff is doing fine Twitter
Mike shaming man yeah definitely is just
the Todd Howard games like if you're
looking at look at how much they've
announced right it just drops 76 they
already you know just to get out in
front of it they announced elder scrolls
they announced what is the star wizard
called StarLink star announced on
Starling it's not a new franchise right
it's darling is installing that that
that uh space game or started star
something whatever something is the new
space game from yeah so that and that's
coming out before Elder Scrolls and it's
just like okay you you need to sort of
and I know they do it's not like they
come out every two or three field yeah
it's not like they come out it it's not
like they come on every two or three
years they do take the time with them
but it just feels like they need to
evolve the formula more um because when
you look at what you know the the
Wolfenstein games the the prey was
actually very good you know for for this
type of game that is um you look at this
honor those games Apollo still doing
great
yes honor is insane yeah what you man so
yeah it was a strong topic we definitely
agree the Lords agree with that and they
it's closer than I expect
you know a lot of people you know but
that's just getting the bed wrap with
this way I think they get people are
piling on I mean you know some touch
sometimes it people don't even play the
games like I refused to comment on Red
Dead or make but if I don't own it
mm-hmm I can't give my opinion on it and
I don't go off of people playing I can't
get on a second experience I'm not about
that that's a good one that's a good
point case that mean absolutely
so we go get into these topics we have
saw four we actually go calm quiet storm
that's a fireside chat
it is his topic and is the game awards
result before we get into that we must
crown the 2018 Lord of the game Lord
sovereign the Sasha Thomas
congratulations sir Chuck my title I
went with my heart a little bit too much
results you you definitely want with the
most ones predictions and then you get
me give us the rundown the rundown but I
forgot to have it in front but I think
you do tell me I think he says reckon
with mods who was on right yeah mods was
right behind me
look uh I think I had eleven he had ten
and then after that was King heard yeah
up followed by cog and then at it in all
fairness we didn't do that well all the
way around like we I think missed
complete
Leon like three different categories we
can put everybody whiffed yeah I think
we'll put me over the top was the dead
cells action game yeah put me over the
top
dead cells puts you up and then King
Kings only one they get the pick out
awards game of the year so he's the one
he cleaned out in that category but it
was yeah it was fun we'll get into your
topic now about these uh the gaming wall
just in general like we'll talk about
what you want talk
well basically like you know this is the
fifth year running for the game awards
um
apart from the show being a little long
and I think that's been a complaint
we've had over the past couple of years
I think it kind of hit its stride this
year in terms of like you know what it's
really all about you know glorifying
these game makers as well as like you
know people in the community and I think
they did a perfect job of sort of doing
that obviously the the big moments you
know having a big three on stage at once
you know dominus I will say this there
is a meme where they have where they got
Rita is Phil's in the mirror and filters
his hey I think I shot the bheegi bheegi
has it unless it's Phil as shortly and
talkative Philip turns his head is what
it means they feel like he said that
with the way you what was funny to me
was G so and Phil
was when Kili was talking to fill alone
right didn't feel look a little like
like he looked a little like awkward
there like he he says yeah big shout out
to Jeff for making this happen like like
he's like he really pushed to make that
in that moment alone he was disgusted
visualization is 90% of the stuff right
and when you saw that's one of me one
out do me one out he was 4k this dude
was 1080p and 360 I'm like Danny like
that I'm looking at it though I
understand understand I said I think the
show kinda head is tried hitting
perfectly between like the announcements
announcements up for this show I mean
it's the biggest thing right we really
watch it for the announcements right
it's all fun and games for when it comes
to the awards and stuff we want to hear
what what new stuff is coming down a
pipeline so I thought I thought it was
perfect in that regard it is kind of a
long show yes and as as live shows go
you always gonna have your weird awkward
moments I know there's been some
commentary online about sonic Fox and
stuff like that but I mean to me it was
his moment he did with it what he he saw
fit and now that's fine by me right I
don't have an issue with that um so now
to like the the big announcements and
for me honestly and I'm not an Ultimate
Alliance guy but that Ultimate Alliance
oh my god what the what's that that was
really out of love people showing that I
was the same way when the show could
have ended King knows right that that's
part of the reason why I got it 50 you
know I'm saying that had to online play
like that is it was every character you
know I'm saying it wasn't just limited
to a specific thing so I always want to
know what ever happened to the you know
the franchise where is it going
Deana see it back now and let's be real
you're it besides the fact is exclusive
the injured numb but the switch is
capable of doing true but it almost was
like I was a cell shady but that it just
looked good yes very cartoony yeah Yosh
out the slow he said he ultimately
basically guarantee I know people that
said what switch I only I'm reading it
that is my heart and then the only thing
I had to worry about saying well let me
let me see is it really gonna be co-op
is it really gonna be all online and I
went to the website did the fact that
they have all that in place man so shout
out that I don't know how switch was
able to keep that probably have the
switch 2.0 you know so they integrate
that they pull a warframe in a fortnight
in superseded Nintendo and just go
around
yes the gaming we got our discord open
so we got that switch gang discord
for those you know see who don't like
the voice chats I'm with you at my side
and then yeah that were those crazy and
then second after that like King
mentioned that MK 11 oh Lord I like the
way they did it you know what they could
be used to that was the most monotone
crappy verse I'm like get out of here
which is banging your garb MK for always
from right King they may have um Khalifa
the last Mortal Kombat no it was that
was that wish for them at least
recognizing hip-hop culture for a lot of
their backdrops and stuff like I know
it's a controversial thing is subjective
I get it you know saying but I always
feel like Watto , always stays closer to
hip-hop then alone you know the music is
a fundamental part of Mortal Kombat it's
like it brings up the essence like
certain boys
yeah you know I'm saying like and
amongst yes I really expect honestly I
know it's kind of cheesy though yeah
that's the lane oh the next thing for me
is funny because the way I felt about it
going into the show changed after stuff
that we just heard from Lord Cognito
about some nd8 stuff Dragon Age like the
announcement for Dragon Age with me it
was just very surface level rice and
letting you know that it's coming right
well a lot there was some speculation
before that is like what we're gonna let
them know it's coming because what we
have coming out in February it might be
a dumpster fire so let's let's let them
know that an actual rate real RPG is
coming um but like well again things
things that have been around Twitter and
whatnot indicate that maybe that's not
the case so now this makes this sort of
very exciting now as to what they're
gonna do with the Dragon Age franchise
again for me the fact that Casey Hudson
is back in a building means that it's
gonna be a certain level of quality
certain level of storytelling in those
games that's gonna bring it it's gonna
bring it back so um I'm excited I think
it's super early to talk about it even
in this form but whatever you know it's
three years out we'll be seeing it on
next consoles but Dragon Age I mean
after that obviously like you know out
for loading fallout is you know the the
outer worlds and of course on the new
Far Cry game yes yes
so the new father I mean this is gonna
be interesting because again with
fallout 76 having the the growing pains
that it's having um and people again for
I like fallout 4 but it was just seemed
like more of the same you know people
were really divided on the whole
crafting stuff in the building stuff so
if these two games touch upon what
people really really really loved about
fallout in a way that these last two
games haven't as much you know I think I
were talking about before it makes a lot
of sense that maybe they put you know
put Fallout away for a little bit and
just let it you know come back with a
fresh take a couple years down the line
let these other people rock out I'm
excited to see what a far cry
that feels like a Fallout game is um and
then the outer world to me that again
arguably the best fallout the best 3d
fallout anyway um absolutely it's I know
it's not exclusive but I think it would
Microsoft would do well to put it in
game past day one oh yeah maybe not only
because of the fact that this was before
the deal yeah no I think honestly from
this day forward even if it's a
multi-platinum showing someplace else if
they own the studio and those games was
in development they're gonna be
launching in game pass the y'all could
pay for it if you'll know Microsoft
Microsoft owns outer world so they own
the IP and Microsoft publishing that
game right well that doesn't matter
microsoft owns they they they have the
right to publish it they don't own the
IP it's like the Rhys thing so you're
saying that the sequel is going to be
exclusive if there's if there's unless
there's multiple games made well under
or dill mm-hmm right I don't know good
point I have to find I have to get some
more information on that yeah some
sources to find out what
because I wasn't any impression
obviously when it got announced that it
wouldn't be exclusive which was we kind
of knew it was not but I don't know
about rights and you know far as
controlling and stuff like that it's
just in the chat your witnesses
mentioned it and said he said yes
obsidian owns IP therefore I don't know
how we got to find out how that works I
mean if a Microsoft has the ability to
put it in yes that'll be a big be a big
blow you know that would be you know
yeah we would want to get it on the
opposition platform if you can kind of
get it so real quick the last couple of
things aside rates to look back to with
those first-person shooters and the
imagining of old franchises that rage
looks insane man so I'm excited yeah oh
yeah played again I'm living it it does
it was super pretty
yeah the only issue people have with it
that the open-world was kind of not as
open as they made it out to be but I
mean the shooting was crazy and shout
out to dizzy and and those arc people
because the Atlas is coming and
apparently it's gonna blow our got the
frame is the e [ __ ] game the guy who
created a Assassin's Creed that looks
that looks weird but you'll see what
that is um and then the last thing yo
persona 5 you guys like you persona fans
are really out there people lost their
minds over the announcement of the Joker
and smash like people lost their damn
exactly just point out that um a bunch
of like trolls
Animal Planet Animal Crossing theme they
made you think it was just right
announcement now they're making you
think of our son of files being
announced but he's just a character in
the game
I mean let me ask you out that's what I
was kind of leading into you smash Tommy
but I want that like because of that you
don't think that maybe it's in the works
I guess it's a good little cross
marketing thing you know with that we
know that's a DLC right we're good that
character that maybe they set up a part
of persona 5 horse which you don't think
that I don't like if that was in the
works it would have been announced to
the video game awards are using this to
gauge interest yeah that's what I'm
saying like it could be a gauge interest
tech to temperature people go crazy
didn't say hey there's a demand for for
this game with that I give you guys the
floor about the show so attic just give
us your overall feel on the game once I
think it was actually is a great show I
think it was too long but besides that
what it showed me is that people were
taking this platform seriously now yeah
I mean just think about it obsidian
announced a brand new I bet that was
that was like III level and far crys
next game was announced there mm-hmm
so you know people are taking it a lot
more serious ante up to your point at it
like I looked at Twitter I looked at
what was trending Game Awards dominated
so yeah all day all day so anybody who
got any questions on whether or not
video games have arrived has like fatah
minute for home in comparison to media I
mean to movies and things of that nature
I haven't seen that level of like
engagement in a long time so yeah man I
mean what do you think bland like how
did you feel about the show in general
to um I echo the same citizens as
everybody besides getting a lid
two long low Indian parts other than
that it was a great show it it achieved
exactly what it set out to achieve
uh-huh I'm a big critic of Jeff Keely
but he did a darn good job with the show
I'm not a hater you did an amazing job
putting together the kind of show that
people want to watch it even raise my
level aches but it takes because I
didn't see the unannounced games and all
of that show
when you made that announcement on
Twitter that that was what the lineup
was gonna be like so and once again two
addicts point is that people who taken a
medium seriously and that's you saying
for me because I've always taken it
seriously so it's nice to see everybody
else's foul coming in too but some of
the big big news for me was a behind yes
crazy the outer worlds next to me I
don't know if you guys talked about this
on the show but when that old deal with
obsidian was announced a lot of people
tried to say oh it's not it's just some
City none to me this cements why they
went out and got those guys because you
know if they could do this imagine what
power with the kind of backing and
budget I think you're on it man because
maybe it really solidified them as a
player yeah far as more in foreign
markets or warchest I mean I know
everybody had you know the ninja tear
reason so we know the initiative but
everybody III even I think I'm guilty of
it like I'm not that I was sleeping but
it just like I just needed to see and
then I saw I was like oh okay I was
going to say could you stop could have
been the game we may have some here even
though even though yeah even though that
could I mean come on that I could have
been a nail in the coffin if that's what
showed him you know this is what they're
capable czar doing imagine what we don't
get them to do with this budget and
these resources are they help you no
accent no point forward you know
everything else would be exclusive come
on I think they spent the most money on
and turns of studios I think obsidian
they spent the most money on
you think so mmm could be you know I'm
sitting in an engine theory well ninja
theory was kind of in a situation I mean
because you know obviously the the gay
hell-blade doing very well at far
exceeded expectations but I still think
they were kind of in a need standpoint
as far as money was in a need standpoint
right obsidian still you know they still
get like people like take to to publish
them so I don't think they were hurting
Artie yeah but at the end of the day I
felt like the key components when they
bought playground because I think that's
what they spent the most besides they
owned all their stuff already so they
didn't really need to pay extra because
they only a peas but obsidian it wasn't
like that like just outer worlds itself
just the concept and what they showed at
the video game awards probably put on
some figures mm-hmm know what you might
be right because now that I'm breaking
it down and I'm looking at it you know
if you go on base by need you gonna go
baseline and maybe they didn't you know
lowball them maybe they actually just
wanted me to knock it out of the park
like you know baseball team trying to
you know get a good player and just
don't go in and BS it but as far as I'm
sitting I really yeah you might be right
on that
obsidian not in the space of really
needing but wanting to be into a more
secure environment as far as resources
and stuff like that goes so I think they
they working and I think yeah I think
price-wise they probably yeah I think if
it's perfectly because if you look at
obsidians last couple of games like
they're great they're great old-school
style classic RPGs but the fact of the
matter is that they that style of game
still isn't remotely as popular as some
like as a big you know third-person
triple-a RPG a just doesn't they don't
resonate the same way so if they can
give their expertise the amount of money
that some of these other other Studios
have yeah I think for them it's just a
matter of being able to expand on the
craft too and not worry about the money
and one thing before we move on the one
thing you want to you guys want to go
back and watch this go back and watch
the city and did a video on YouTube
after the purchase was made
I'm saying it what's going on very
similar to a ninja Tori did and what I
did recognize is that both Studios said
the exact same thing about the way Xbox
approached the acquisitions you're not
only they did not show up to take over
right they showed up because they wanted
to help because the narrator behind
Microsoft that they metal - Musti but
they fingers right on all this so I
think that's a prepared statement that
they have to give out - sure the crowds
that you know listen here they're not
meddling and to quell all that extra
noise before the noise even starts yeah
no I agree and then King as you mean you
both know I mean we know when we spoke
to those school Studios right yeah agree
you spoke to ninja theory and I'm saying
I spoke to a compulsion and stuff like
that and instated ain't no obviously uh
undead labs are good friends
Richie fogey yes you know that the
narrative has been consistent if you
know the one I'm gonna really take his
opinion on and and and this is the
reason why because fogies a friend right
and that's that's that's a completely
different thing and off the record you
know he was like yo not for real for
real
so and I'm not you know exposing
anything other than what other than that
on the wreckage so it was it anything
different you know opposed to you know
on the record or off the record type of
thing and I don't really say I have a
personal relationship with the other my
Studios so when he sounds like real like
not a really opening the coffers and
they allowing you that space to move
because I think in the past they noticed
what they were doing in the past and it
just didn't work right yeah so in order
for a company to actually and this is a
page from Sony because you got because
credit to Sony's do fax know you know
Sony gave that roadmap mmm with these
games that are actually thriving II
single-player games that you know Phil
said there is a space for because people
lie lied and said yo you know feels a
dead dead no there's a space forum and
what he was trying to explain is after
the point of release and
to the wilds the revenue stream and
getting money back from said project is
very limited so how we present it to the
public has to be a little bit different
than how they're doing it now now no
people who's gonna sit there and say
well God of War shows you that you can
make money over this IP and in the
single-player experience but they didn't
keep that same mindset going into
spider-man when Spiderman make equal
amounts of money but the DLC tacked on
to it made more revenue and I'm me
personally I'm looking for that deal
he'll see for God why I swear I remade a
pop-up hoping that they let your DLC
inbound
he's a very quality and I think yes and
the thing is like we need God of War is
like it is an outlier at games of that
quality to take that long to make though
you're not gonna get that all the time
so the vast majority of single-player
games and stuff of that ilk you're not
getting a God of War quality game you
know every single year so yeah they have
to look at it they have to look at the
model differently because you know God
wore only God of War is gonna make that
kind of money only spider-man's gonna
make that kind of money only and
uncharted is gonna come close to me or
the Last of Us it's gonna come to making
that kind of money so you have to have
something in place that allows you to
monetize those games and make more money
off of them and in a way that you know
in a way that isn't gross to the
consumer and keeps the IP alive in
people's minds absolutely let me jump in
man um yeah like this in the show I felt
it was I thought this was the best game
Awards I mean yeah just long yeah it has
some parts you know I feel bad for Jeff
King sometimes because you're not gonna
please everybody there's always gonna be
people who knock on like the music
choices you know saying oh there's
always gonna be people the only only
complaint i legit had was okay look I'm
all about the eSports community that's
cool but I don't feel they should kind
of dominate as far as the awards I feel
like all like a previous way like there
was some times when God a war won an
award he was like oh yeah by the way
they won that water when it this war -
I'm like how you ain't showdown on
screen but you can't
but it's just like I don't like window
wars is just like oh yeah by the way
this game won that - really I just read
you know I'm saying like so again I
understand we got a lot of personalities
and stuff I just wish the games would be
more of a focus that's just my nitpick
I'm not really going in you know I'm
saying like that's what the whole thing
but as far as like two things obviously
saw stole my point cuz waffles middle
eyes man muscle there's a game for me
too I know y'all talking about outer
worlds that was amazing but that there's
a game called the pathless that's going
had that looked hot yeah she look like
jinx from GI Joes yeah she had the red
ninja suit it's a ninja game you already
know right so I'm like okay that's it
but um yeah I was away I thought it was
good because of the drama of the show
like let's be really are like we all
thought the way this show started Red
Dead was cleaning every more you would
have thought needed yeah narrative I'm
like is there any reason for me to still
watch this like the way this is going
so I'm Sydney and then I'm like you know
pour out a little liquor for our liquid
you know I thought they had a shot at
all or what you call it multi play or
maybe you know whatever and then
spider-man and Assassin's Creed I'm like
oh this is crazy and um as it went on
you know saying then you get the
build-up a shout out to the orchestra
that does the game music they don't get
enough credit like when they do to God
what I'm gonna do the game of the year
and then before they do it they play
like the deans of that game soundtrack
like that's me that's what people hate
known as like to me I thought that was
though I was very games you know
oh my figured you young generation but
seriously like I loved that joint but to
be really it was looking real spooky for
God of War keep it really are like I did
forgive me my my game award show give me
the highlights and give me exactly what
I cared about not really too much but
just show me the game that was announced
in the games that are noteworthy did
that long dramatize feel you about I
feel like that but I thought it was like
a cool moment when they did we got what
did win it had everybody all riled up
but regardless of whatever side of the
fence you were on Oh Jade of stole Jade
yes it was wide open and I was looking
spooky to waste artists Oh shout out to
those guys I didn't read their fans to
the end of the day they still cleaned up
you know I mean I saw attic I saw your
tweet you seem to be popping bottles
when got a war one as you feel about
that people acting like God of War was
like the little engine that could not
like Celeste one like when they said God
a war one you was like not as [ __ ]
no I was fine with it but people acting
like there was this huge underdog this
hundred million dollar game was huge
versus Ghana war I don't got a war was
if you think about how long god what do
you what are you say are you going off
dates now I'm just talking about you
actually like actually like an indie
game won Game of the Year like no you
gotta say you've read big guys shout the
phones like yeah when y'all talk and
your mind there is nothing else even in
the scope so it may got a war feel like
an indie game it may got a war feel like
it didn't have a chance to is how crazy
is that right based on how a beginning
to the year
Himanshu how did go to whirlwind Game of
the Year it lost every other reward was
in from yeah I was like I'm not gonna
say to figure it literally felt like
what am I here for because they're going
to clean every award that was that I
thought that the other games had a shot
like a Detroit despise Detroit they gave
it to all the game not saying none of it
is not deserve but we just felt that if
anything was gonna beat Red Dead in
these other categories it was gonna be
the most categories right so when you
see narrative and when you see best
performance and I'm like damn Morgan
wanted this I'm like a weird we're how
did God war win it when it lost all the
other what's the biggest thing for a lot
of people that was a huge lot of people
because but but I wasn't of gang it was
I think it was regardless of you know
how what whatever budget just came had
how powerful it is it is it was kind of
a feel-good moment like you know Corie
Corie bar log like he detailed his
entire like journey coming back to make
this game like it was the most besides
Celeste it was probably the best most
feel-good moment that was the moment
right you felt because neither you were
happy because you felt if you're a guy
cigar wolf and you felt as the underdog
coming energy right and you succeeded or
you're a red dead and you were
overconfident like oh this is in a
better anything about this this isn't
this isn't like not normal for the wars
remember when overwatch beat
I don't remember the wild feed oh well
be somebody last year another game
yeah it's something yeah it was another
game I can't think of Mike this happened
was one fallout 4 and Witcher was going
against each other yeah tough one too it
was a good one and that's why I felt it
was one of the best of what I understand
over the chat because of the majority of
the voters opinions read their identity
was superior in individual aspects of
achievement or partial skill but God a
war was the better total package from
beginning to end and I just think at the
end of the day regardless whatever side
of the fence you're on because I guess
it's all subjective right at the end of
day it's whatever your personal game in
worth but it was just it was a fact and
Spiderman was up in it too but I just
feel it was like we have arrived right
and I feel good and soon it would be
mentioning the breadth of the Oscars and
the Emmys and all we have I guess
regardless of however you fail in gaming
that was a moment this week that was a
moment how whatever side of the fence
you wore you were super emotional one
way or you super motion the other way
and I think at the end of the day that's
what made it dope for me because I never
seen twitter twitter was lit gram BAM I
think the reason that people were the
most upset is because we got to the game
of the Year nominations and at that
point right dad pulling everything
everyone was pretty much like yeah God
of War is not winning this it's whole
was set earlier but no they started
doing the best so they waited to all
to the big three kono stage yeah like I
just at the end of the day I agree with
everything you guys have said I think
this was the this was the show that
really got it all right and showed like
it showed what the video game industry
is and I think you know say feel how you
will about Jeff Keely um I think he's
perfectly positioned to give us that
type of show right back when this these
awards started you know you had Sam
Jackson you know hosting it wasn't it
was more of a pop culture thing yeah it
wasn't about gaming as much and I think
somebody like Keely at the helm of it
it's gonna be focused on gaming and what
we want it to be so I think it's only
it's only gonna get better and they
always bring that they show quality I'm
not gonna miss him this year yeah man so
let's get it - and we don't talk too
long but um yeah man so uh what is it
it's not our Lord and it's Phil
diatomite so he has my recent remarks
recently uh got everybody in a tizzy so
uh recently looks like there was an arm
in a conference in a San Francisco the
Barclays conference aw Phil Spencer you
talked about
I'll see not only one to bring our game
past the PC which also Sachin and also
revealed early year but also to every
device
and he said eventually when it comes to
more platforms like mobile to streaming
will help Xbox reach billions of gamers
instead of millions and I'm a quote Lord
Phil he says when you think about
reaching a customer with this content
we're the only compute device can be an
Android phone you think about what are
all the ways that person plays for
content today so we need to make sure
that did a world-class free-to-play
content but also looking at
subscriptions and much as a lower
barrier wave for customers to build a
library of content so he said we built
it Xbox game passed on console will come
to PC and then the key word I got
everyone in a tittie talked about it so
wanna bring this to the roundtable you
know when you hear what Phil say these
comments and that use the terminology
every device do you think this will be
game pass for Nintendo switch and
PlayStation 5 so let's start with Lord
blam not not necessarily not right after
cuz I know I don't know I mean it's
still at the end of the day that's I
don't know who get to that point like
where they're putting their stuff on
Nintendo and Sony as well but I think
what he means essentially is that what
they've done what they wanted from the
beginning is that there reaches many
people as they possibly can including PC
Mobile which goes back to the statement
he member he stated that his next big
thing on his laundry list is the Windows
Store that's the next thing on his
laundry list or is checking off that box
so this makes sense that he would say
this right after saying that so I mean
to me I just think he means other
platforms Mobile is the next big thing
we've already heard about the whole
explain that how that's supposed to be
working essentially with that they're
they're gonna be streaming games and if
they can get that the cloud is your
service up and running I know we talked
about a little bit on the show the other
day where I heard they were putting
servers in all these different countries
I mean there's your is everywhere but a
ton of places
it's not so as soon as they get these
farms up and running hopefully that's
the infrastructure that they're
imagining running everything off of so I
don't know about being on like Sony or
being on Nintendo but I know they're
literally trying to reach as many people
as they possibly can mobile markets are
huge and a lot of these other countries
Japan India as a billion people in the
country have cell phones thanks well
they say you gotta you gotta reach those
people you know I'm saying that they're
highly technically evolved as well you
know make a country like India would be
but they really are as far as like China
Japan as well so I think that's more so
what he needs 4l but it could be
anything maybe even so maybe even
Nintendo you know what joined in afraid
some who think there's a possibility I
mean think about it because you look at
Amazon and Google Amazon is look at
these top secured in the video games mmm
there are licking their chops are doing
something video game related I can't not
I mean I'm seeing Google not too far
behind there as well so who knows if
they if Amazon throws his hat in the
ring then we'll see because that's a
huge player that's a huge player they
already got studios don't they all right
a yep thanks go to ng CryEngine sorry
exactly I said I remember seeing on
Twitter there was a video going around a
couple of this way didn't they purchase
the studio that made the fighting game
for the Xbox what's the what's the
fighting the second studio that took
over making a fighting game oh
iron iron galaxies yeah yeah they
purchased them to make earrings okay no
see if they thought I had no doubt let
me get a lord addict
man what do you feel when you hear Phil
make these comments every device is that
Nintendo switch in PlayStation 5 to you
I think it's I think it's sad this man
can't even go on and say stuff like that
what people taking it and run
he every time that he is referred to the
PlayStation or he's always he's always
referred it as a platform mmm devices is
generally used for you know phones
tablets you don't really see too many
people refer to a Playstation as a
device mmm okay I see we go mmm it's you
know it's just people going with a
narrative for some reason it's like it's
like I said a lot of people think these
Studios that they're making back they're
gonna be making multiplex I'm like when
because of Minecraft people be thinking
every game that they're making is going
to be minecraft hmm my craft is a lot of
people you know fella realize minecraft
wasn't bought by the gaming division was
bought by the entire company as a whole
and that's why it's on every platform
god yeah yeah hey man I mean I hate
going with that so again just for the
record
Lord addict you feel strictly devices
mobile phones tablets things of that ilk
- you think this is people blowing this
out of proportion
they're just trying to it's like the
whole thing when he said single-player
games don't have the you know the
strength that they did 10 15 years ago
he wasn't wrong but people I took that
they took that narrative and then they
threw it and said the he thinks that
they're irrelevant which he never said
that right that is true he did not say
he didn't think they were remote you're
correct all right let's get lost soft
what do you feel about every device yeah
I mean I agree with addict and blame I
think it's the same thing I think it's
the words were misconstrued a little bit
um I think at this point let's talk
about the beginning of the generation
right when when Xbox said the name of
Xbox are sort of down in the dregs I on
this we've had the conversations on this
podcast about what happens if they just
decide to to make Xbox a platform you
know ubiquitous of an actual piece of
hardware and just put it everywhere then
yeah that possibility maybe exists that
they'd be on other platforms like
PlayStation and that and
Nintendo but that's not the case anymore
that's not the case anymore like we fill
out the helm to be honest like you know
and he's got such his ear gaming and
Xbox at Microsoft I don't feel this
going anywhere I think it's gonna be the
central pillar of what obviously what
gaming is at Microsoft so yeah as for me
it's about getting it on on every single
device that you can get your hands on
its mobile you know home based whatever
the case may be you know on your Roku
stick or whatever the heck it may be
they just want to get game paths and and
the Xbox Store on that so will might
there be instances specific instances
like they showed Whitten you know a
Nintendo that yeah you know certain
conversations can be had about certain
crossovers that make sense that are not
intrusive to both people's IP to both
companies IPO or not and make sense for
both companies to make money that
that'll definitely happen but yeah
they're not gonna be on PS 5 and they're
not gonna be on you know anytime soon
but they will be they will be on you
know every tablet that you can possibly
imagine every phone that you could
possibly imagine and I think that my ex
club but by you know getting on every
device is X Club absolutely that's what
he wins all this 5g talk and explore x
cloud talk that's what the he's talking
about okay Lord King what does Phil
Dominus mean took the ship turned it
around and staring in the right
direction now um very key to what lo
Cognito has said if y'all was listening
he said removing barriers the biggest
barrier that Microsoft has when it comes
to getting game passed to everybody uh
is xbox live right right so I think in
him saying that that was like a coded
message and letting you know that Xbox
Live is going to go the way of the
dinosaurs the paid barrier and it's
going to be that fee for game pass so I
think game paths will be a requirement
for you to get all those other services
that might like you know like party chat
I think it's gonna be coming free
multiplayer games as far as joining your
friends and stuff like that I think
that's gonna become free once it removed
that barrier and only paid for service
on the system is they could probably
roll it into one I believe I don't know
who said I want to give proper credit to
women I don't know who said it before
but another podcaster or youtuber has
said it before then they believe and it
could be Tim dog I believe hmm they said
I believe that they're going to remove
that because that's a bigger barrier
opposed to getting it on every device
this is just an app and I think it - oh
yes cell phones it's just an app that
you can get on your tablets and he's not
going to bring it up I'm pretty sure you
will love to bring it to a switch and
get it on to a Playstation
but unless Sony is dead um unless a
Nintendo is completely in the bushes
that's never gonna happen those
platforms have their own ideologies they
have their own fan bases and that will
totally roll their fan base away from
them if that was allowed to happen so no
cell phones yes uh you know billions of
people everyone imaginable has a cell
phone even a little kids nowadays um
tablets yes do you maybe a to be on
Amazon as an app ruku sticks like uh
like lamps said you know I can see it in
those places I would I can't see it on a
switch and I definitely do not ever
think that it will make any type of
iteration on a Playstation ever all
right I think I'm up I'm here to piss
everyone off yeah so I sorta statement
obviously we saw what's going on you
know saying sort of narratives fanboys
running with it
listen it's why I think I've been in
short term this definitely I agree with
the Lord I agree with you blam this
definitely applies to tab
it's mobile and I think obviously people
sleeping on TV so I think that that's a
huge media you know especially if like
you know project s cloud to be imagined
the way we you don't do as it's
extremely low latency platform you don't
you know your little Samsung TV it's
only TV you know I'm saying you got an
app all you got to do is bring
controller to somebody's house and you
have game pass that is extremely
attractive so I think we're sleeping on
that but um you know listen Microsoft's
in the business of selling services and
software they want to go where you are
and where they theoretically would not
reach there on their own or the
traditional console so in that respect I
do think the Xbox console is not going
anywhere right there's always gonna be
dedicated hardware for the base however
I do think if it's up to Microsoft they
with what game fast app on a PlayStation
2 switch you know say it's just about
reach like similar to PC when that was
announced fanboys was an uproar like ah
but if you look at it that was the
Trojan horse right there was that wasn't
people was like this is not exclusive
you are putting it on data that I and
Microsoft don't care the same pockets
yeah it looked for all this fanboy stuff
about always notic school they don't
mean nothing it's money in a pocket when
you copped all PC yes and laughs to the
bank hey you know who did that for you
so our core gamers are thinking just
wait from a way too emotional Stabler
this is business I could totally see
Microsoft approaching the big - you know
with somebody that game they probably
approach them back to be real man that
kid I think glass out the blame I think
you said it on his shop real well we saw
Phil Sean and all Reggie didn't you
think maybe some type of game cross
thing was going on out
yeah absolutely right away they about to
break the Internet right now but I
thought it might go down right then I
could totally see them approaching the
question comes down to not Microsoft
with baby actually cool we're doing it
see the only one I see is Stan Tendo as
a possibility
Sony oh they too invested in their own
self
you know I'm saying and they not enough
that their business are helping me
competitor you know we already seen
we're fortnight with Dell they had to go
kicking and scratching and fight in and
still we don't have an official
announcement as witness going down how's
it going down anybody know for a fact
well fortnight cross wait you don't sell
or smoke it's 31 down so it's down
officially my cousin sage has been
flying with his friends on playstation
fair not fair anybody know so my thing
is just like but you see how resistant
they were and it had to take a cultural
phenomenon that is for at night to get
that to happen still we ever heard
really much on any other of games and
shout out to Jonathan B yes Sony won't
even allow EA access I agree Sony is to
me the person that would say nah fam
we're not making no money over here so
again I could see Microsoft approaching
it like let's slip the Trojan horse it
over in a different position that their
mobile you know they look at themselves
kind of like a handheld damn they're
just got you Tony can get a cut they
will do it and I say I think ultimately
that's where the business was falling
all out at right so the angle allowed
them to come over
I don't care in the business of helping
people edge idli trying to acquire a
b-level studio from a predominantly Sony
developer and the speculation this is
what I bring to the group who do we
speculate is that developer and when
they make their move is it gonna feel
like feces in the side don't question
the question basically comes down to you
they the rumors are making again we got
further we got a shout out the sauce cuz
Lord crow grill
he's crazy he's batting a thousand he's
batting a thousand and I wanna I want to
double in your point King cuz you're
making a fantastic point with not only
is he saying that marks what was this
room they looking at Tommy saying some
crazy yeah suicide and you know well
going so the first one he said which is
King is talking about which is Ron
Johnson talked with a historically
PlayStation developer about joining Xbox
Studios as a first party developer who
the hell could that be
without here make him back backyard he's
a beloved Xbox IP you haven't probably
played in the last four years will soon
get its bold second title in the
next-gen the successor is deep in
development and I expect you will hear
about it in 20 and 21 oh no these are H
balls let's get our tinfoil hat on let's
get up let's get out the first ball it
was so nice to do [ __ ] we did y'all
crazy if you think about it like a whole
studio not like a developer like a whole
studio insomniac ready at dawn getting
disney money then it going or how smokey
supermassive quandary I think it might
be Superman supermassive potentially
right if you know the super mass is
starting to make multi planets I need
you man what do you think with the first
one oh my my my initial reaction was
House mark because house mark the king
of the kings of the twin-stick shooters
they kind of said like look we're gonna
move away from that cuz it's not really
making us the money that we would like
to make it's just not they're not as
popular as they were they're not they
don't have it indicated that they're
making anything right now so it would
make the most sense like if you look at
uh you know already at dawn if you look
at all
what is dr the untold on developer
supermassive sorry yes supermassive is
making the the third party game man of
made on snow like this stuff in
development that may make it difficult
for Microsoft just to snatch them up in
the middle of that I don't know what
kind of deals are there so multiple
studios yeah happy for you yes true but
yeah so it's those that may order 18
whatever the quality level of that game
that game I still think deserves as a
sequel I think I love that world the
game was just a little bit boring but
beyond that everything else around the
game was great yeah so I mean I would
love Lydia corn another thing when you
look at all not ready I don't when you
look at a supermassive I think they're
types of games if you look at until dawn
if you look at what they do one man have
made on they sort of fit perfectly into
that on that episodic sort of a Content
that concise Quantic as well yeah we
talked to set out to wrap in a brat
podcast we talked about that on
Wednesday they yeah like it would fit
perfectly into something like game past
because it goes back to Phil still
hasn't done anything with with episodic
games the way he mentioned that he'd
like to utilize game past so one of
those Studios like a Quantic Dream or
super massive sort of fits perfectly
into that but me being just conservative
I'll say house mark just because I don't
know that they have anything on the
table and it'd be interesting to see
them do something other than the
twin-stick shooter so yeah how smart
this is one that we've talked about
before but it's a little left-field and
I didn't even know this about the studio
but on the shop archives yesterday
somebody mentioned sumo digital as well
because pass to more digital has I can't
repeat specific list of games but it's a
couple games and they work with and
think about this it's kind of
interesting Zoomer it'll save crack ram
what other studio besides Forza besides
a turn 10 or lay grounds has any will
besides besides those two studios you
know that is actively working with the
clouds it is probably the realistic
answer and I've just bad because that's
over any chat or Lord and always
corrected he says sumo digital has five
studios and over 500 developers he said
there's nothing mid-south I could be
true because the key that's in the Clos
brocro is that it is midsize inside that
we got eliminate a lot of these bigger
and stammers Lausanne is right about
that okay cool well then okay well that
was just that was the one thing that was
[ __ ] as well but I did we were talking
about these supermassive is already
add-ons as well Blue Point was another
one people talked about those are like
the remaster Kings fit right along with
you know remasters like Blue Point would
be the best one big Blue Point attic
attic who do you want that's what our
good thing about Blue Point is they they
already said they're working on
something else they didn't say that it
was specifically a stony thing although
they had early terms of negotiations
with them now they just do about it
[Laughter]
they really burn up in flames like I
really like that game I thought it was
underappreciated underrated and shot the
anchored ad I think our cologne and
anchorman has been champion in that game
and you played that game King right yeah
so you know trying to get
through it because it puts you to sleep
but um the game like visually that was
the high-water mark for me when Rhys was
kicking me teeth and then put the hole
and I was like oh I got some stuff
mm-hmm and I I thought like the
storytelling it was great it was just
the pacing of the game was off and I
said you know the studio I guess they
needed a little bit time to bake but at
that time PlayStation didn't have a lot
of games out and it had to get that game
out the door I think it stood in a
little too long in them they wanted it
out like first year something like that
boy mom I want that that studio if I had
to pick I think that studio has the
chops to deliver a home run at some
point in time yeah I'd be a nice one
let's get it today second one real quick
I know and we gotta kiss solving first
cuz yeah I know what it is so the second
one a beloved Xbox IP air guys we
haven't played in the last four years
that will get its bold second title in
the next-gen saw what you think and what
you want no man I convinced something
that's been dormant for quite some time
some candidates man who who could be in
a mixed who we say like I don't you know
my heart is rise but I don't think it
qualifies because um I don't think
Microsoft you know oh yeah now 2013 now
what he's saying is seem it seems more
like leaning towards quantum break
that's what I was thinking quantum break
or maybe the sunset overdrive qualifier
the whole time sunset does does qualify
because also insomniac there stated on
Twitter that they would they would
yes David but here's the thing I don't
think time to make it like they said
deep development you mean it it tell me
they've been making spy spider-man I
mean I don't know you're right it was
done I don't know all I know is that it
didn't sunset just come out on PC yeah
yeah say that game was done and it was
looking for Microsoft to purchase it
something like that
no they just said they they had the idea
they knew exactly what am i know the
game is sunset owned by Microsoft is
that is that thing is Microsoft's idea
Krrish no no no because the part so
remember remember the whole issue was
sodium inside me I went to Sony first
it's in Sony to own the game it's our
exit know Microsoft let's it's not me I
keep the game that's why they are
qualifies them then so then which poly
brings us back to what addict is saying
which is quantum break and that makes
sense I mean it didn't have a portable
things that doesn't make sense to me as
quantum breaks probably been like the
biggest financial hole they've ever been
in this whole generation right and what
that studio is not so great right well
what else could it be perfect arse
another one I mean killer instinct but I
don't I said beloved I'm not going oh I
think this is it
what you thinking because they gave you
the back compatible game I think it was
four years ago which one which one
blinks Oh Lord conquers quest
finally you got you bet over super lucky
tales - just came out and that wasn't
even a joint everybody going in on that
game is good man
I think it's quantum break - gotta break
- it could be it could be banjo it could
be comes if you got us yes and it could
also be something that's beloved that we
don't add I never really play but people
really love this game is Viva Pinata
series no hope for me and rise Marius
that's what I want
Rome dad that was gonna be too mean I
could have been a little god of war
right we're talking us you go and do it
I'm not an art I'm talking yeah I know
you know what what look man at the end
of the day our chance to play too much
with no snatch has dropped so I'll give
it to armed solve who has played it on
my ass I'm assuming Lord blab and
lurking did not pick up / so Lois aw
that's interesting me things to say in
the pre-show or
what did you feel like I said like I'm I
am never played smash before when smash
was popular on the n64 and GameCube we
were already playing we were playing a
lot attacking we were playing a lot of
the Aki wrestling games I was not into
smash you know I was I just thought it
was Kitty and I didn't want anything to
do with it now that I'm older I play
whatever and I'm I'm I was interested to
see what the whole fuss is about with
this game picked it up why you just
wanted something to play on the switch
and flag are in big play like I said
earlier like they have a new fan in me
um they really do um the only gripe I
have I have it I looked it up online I
guess people have had describe that are
new to it um I don't like the fact that
you can only play with analog because it
feels like it's not precise but I guess
that's part of it it's something you got
to get used to so you know I'm gonna do
my due diligence and try to get better
at that but I mean honestly just
everything that the game has the story
mode is what every sort of game fighting
game story mode should be like you know
that I'm looking at you Soul Calibur so
I didn't like their story mode this year
was yeah it was kind of gross to me ya
know I know the argument about is not a
fighting game is this any other there is
from what I see you look very little bit
there is a lot of strategy involved it's
just a matter of you I'll say like it's
not it is not as deep as other fighting
games like seconds and your soul calibur
is not but the appeal of it to me is
less so the fighting than a whole
package then is name it's a museum it's
like a what you like a comic book
crossover
[Laughter]
playing it he was gonna get it down with
that right all right so cool we already
knew that anyway was probably the only
one that watched that smash and he said
it was that they did the Nintendo Direct
was outstanding
who should remember that yeah he said
you guys were frauds with that stuff
around it like now I could not watch
like hours upon smash stuff that I did
not want to do I and you got two buttons
that you to dominate you use jump and
punch jump and punch punch my son is
gonna love this game but I'll make it
shirt they're gonna annoy the Lord I
don't want any more fraud listen man
it's a love letter to everyda Tendo
franchise and obviously Sony franchising
other games and the gameplay is great I
actually played a little bit the only
thing is I'm just a new so I'm just
gonna get destroyed so I don't really
I'm not I don't know the mechanics the
deep mechanics of a smash but as far as
all the features on the mold it's
fantastic had a good time and we'll see
you know as it goes on what they gonna
do but I tell you this that DLC already
set it off with the persona I mean if
they continue that path of bringing in
I'm tell you right now one of them DLCs
is Master Chief
exactly if they stick to this getting
those fantastic append and call it a day
stick to the script of getting
franchises or other games that you don't
think they got some um new ILP people
this week so in regards to Phil
Spencer's latest comments regarding
roblox Phil Dominus regarding Xbox game
paths eventually coming to every device
do you interpret this as game pass
definitely coming to PlayStation
Nintendo Swift yes Phil is literally
spelling it out for you no complete
overreaction strictly project X cloud
phones and tablets or C I don't care
unless I could run game pass on my
blender and toaster when it goes up with
Twitter tomorrow Lord blam and finds me
what you got going on sir
oh man you guys can find me on youtube
blam everywhere Xbox Live ptk planned as
well it's actually on on Twitter's my
first and last name so glad yeah you got
a shot you can shop I guess it's weird
because I'm in Arizona bro in my time
change anytime I tell somebody right now
it's about sometimes in specific so it's
it it goes all over the place right now
time 5 p.m. on Saturdays come join us
fan you guys now that I want to say this
now that you guys are all welcome to
some one of the shows guys are all like
family
two hours two hours thank you honor to
come on the round table thank you thank
you thank you for coming appreciated man
Lord saw us get you out of here first
because I know you in your phone I'll
stick around to the end
Addie's addict still with us what he had
to go to North High School oh I
appreciate you I know you feeling like
crap man oh where can the fire people
find you what you got going on you got
anymore ashin abbreviated for you but
much appreciated where can find people
find you thank you
first off shots of lemon absolute legend
absolute pleasure to have you on
oh yeah and Lady Savas appreciative as
well for the for the brevity to go along
thank you thank you know you guys can
catch me on Twitter Lord servile pbx
sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live I will be
playing some more smashed as we can
hopefully get back
it's fantastic thank you for coming
through it was beautiful thank you for
[Laughter]
[Music]
this I told you with the Party City and
I'm in the building
I'm not playing appreciate you for
coming through and if I can make that
mountain time you know here man yeah
blam once again absolute pleasure man
long overdue so much fun good last
knowledge will do please check out the
shot podcast man guys got good content
good guest shout out his team Zorka
fuzzy jarhead you know I'm saying a
bunch of good guys and you will get some
information there so check them out man
and um yeah actually make sure you like
subscribe you know all the media outlets
to Spotify iTunes SoundCloud Google Play
all that stuff will go up later tonight
by Lloyd Carr Basu the links will be in
the description also want a shout to
stream team the amazing l-boogie Lord
smiled oh Lord MJ Lord Delap Oh mr.
potentially perfect himself and of
course we have on new video actually
BIOS novel up right now on that uh
mutant
Year Zero first look check that out did
a fantastic job on that please check
that out obviously we know flashpoint
Feeny Von Teese is up talking
or the black armory drama and all that
good stuff it coming soon we probably
have another giveaway going up Mia
solving a lot us now that we'll talk
about that later but uh that's all I got
if any of the Lord's got anything else
when his glorious Sunday all right we
good everybody enjoy we catch you next
week peace